today we're going to do goodie bag 4
vesper our objective is to visualize the
3-dimensional structure
of some simple chemical compounds the
only thing you'll need is a molecular
modeling kit
a conceptual question you should think
about today is what factors determine
how bonds rotate in a molecule
so the first thing we're going to do is
draw the lewis structure for this
molecule
so we know that s i s and c n
since they have between three and five
valence electrons
make up the backbone of this molecule
and then we're going to add
all of the atoms around each of these
backbone atoms
then counting valence electrons we're
going to make sure that we have the
correct
number of non-bonding pairs and bonds
[Applause]
and this will allow us to identify the
geometry at each atom in the backbone
so this silicon bond here
has four bonding domains and all of them
are bonded to another atom
so we know that this is going to be a
tetragonal geometry
this bond here centered around the
sulfur
has five body domains and one of them
is a non-bonding pair we know that this
will be a seesaw geometry
and then finally this carbon has two
body domains with atoms in each of those
domains
so this will be a linear geometry and
now we're ready to build our model
uh
so first we're going to draw the lewis
structure for this molecule
as with before we're going to identify
the backbone atoms in this molecule
so in this case the backbone atoms are c
b and o and now we're going to attach
the other atoms to them
and now we're going to check and make
sure that they're the proper number of
valence electrons around each atom
next we're going to identify the
geometry at each of the backbone atoms
so the first geometry centered around
this carbon atom here has
four bonding domains all of which
contain bonds to other atoms
so that's going to be tetragon the
second geometry
has three bonding domains all of which
are bonded to other atoms
so this is going to be a trigonal planar
geometry
and finally the geometry around this
oxygen atom
has four bonding domains two of which
are bonded
two atoms and two of which are occupied
by lone pairs
so that's going to be a bent geometry
and now we're ready to construct our
bottle
the goody bag 4 worksheet asks us
whether some different bonds can be in
the same plane
so first it asks whether this h
s i s i s and c
n bond can be in the same plane remember
that the c
n bond cannot rotate because it's a
triple bond
but we can rotate around this s-s-i bond
and get all three of the bonds to be in
the same plane the plane shown with my
hand here
so here is our first bond here is our
second bond
and here is our third bond all in the
same plane
next it asks if we can have this h
s i s f and c
n bond in the same plane and so we can
try to rotate
to achieve this but we notice that this
isn't possible because
these two bonds are always in the same
plane and we can't get any of these
bonds
into that plane because of the c saw
geometry
so for our second molecule here the
goody bag worksheet asks a different
question
we notice that this central cb bond can
rotate
and the goodie bag asks which
configuration is the lowest energy
so remember that the entire vesper model
is centered around the idea that we want
to minimize
repulsion between electron clouds by
maximizing the distance between them
so we're going to rotate this so that
the repulsion between
these groups in the molecules are
minimized so as we rotate this we notice
that there are two different
possibilities
remember that these green atoms are cl
and this yellow atom is oxygen these are
the largest atoms
in our model and also the ones that have
the most repulsive electron clouds
so we're going to want to maximize the
distance between them
so one way that this can be achieved is
by rotating the model
so that the oxygen is aligned with the
hydrogen which has a very small
electron cloud and thus is capable of
only very slight repulsion
so this configuration is low energy
because the very repulsive chlorine
atoms
are far from the repulsive oxygen atom
however there's also
a different possibility if we rotate we
can put the oxygen atom
in a plane in between the two chlorine
atoms
so that the oxygen is not directly
facing an
atom however this configuration
puts the oxygen atom spatially closer
to a chlorine atom as shown here and
this hydrogen atom is very close to this
chlorine atom so the first configuration
is lower energy
today we used our molecular modeling
kits to visualize the 3d structure of
some simple molecules
using the vesper model by playing with
these bonds and rotating them
we were able to understand how repulsion
between atoms
gives rise to low the lowest energy
configurations of these molecules